why is too much breath a bad thing i
would have thought more breath would be
good
yeah and a lot of people thought more
food would be good uh because more food
equals more energy so
what's very confusing when you get into
the biochemistry of breathing and this
took me months and months i don't have a
background in this stuff which was a
real hindrance it was a pretty steep
learning curve is that you start to
understand it's the efficiency of breath
that is so much more important than the
volume so a lot of us think we want more
energy right we want more oxygen we need
more oxygen to get more energy so i'm
going to breathe more that allows me to
get more energy it's completely false so
the opposite is true and we've known
this for more than 120 years
that when you breathe over breathe
over your metabolic needs
you offload too much carbon dioxide
without getting too deeply into the
weeds here what that does is it inhibits
blood flow throughout your body and it
makes it harder for you to get oxygen
you can see this for yourself by over
take 10 or 20 very deep breaths and
you'll feel some tingling in your
fingers and in your head
that's from a decrease of circulation
so in order to get the optimum amount of
oxygen you should be be breathing slowly
you should be breathing low you should
be breathing through your nose by doing
that you are pressurizing that air and
you're allowing that air more time in
your lungs to travel down deeper where
that gas exchange can happen so much
more efficiently
you get more oxygen with less work and
less wear and tear on your body
breathing this way and you can see this
by feeling your heart rate when you
breathe in these slower breaths and then
if you have a pulse oximeter a lot of
people do nowadays look at your blood
oxygen levels if anything they'll stay
the same or often go up
so this is just simple mathematics and
yet we've gotten this so wrong
for so long and it's great that people
are starting to correct this and again
we have wearables that can show us and
can prove to us
how we're breathing how efficiently we
should be breathing in the future what
are some of the health effects of poor
breathing then if someone doesn't fix
the awful instructions you've given
well look look around look at the rates
of asthma look at the rates of panic
disorder look at the rates of sinusitis
of increased risk of allergies increased
risk of snoring increased risk of sleep
apnea diabetes is tied to disorder
breathing as well i mean this list goes
on and on because if you're struggling
or if you're doing anything
inadequately all day long all night long
guess what's going to happen your body
can keep itself alive
that's good but it can't keep itself
healthy
so it really starts with
stopping mouth breathing
and this is the number one thing look at
nature look at any other animal in the
wild look at how they're breathing right
they're breathing through their nose
look at an infant breathing deep into
the belly into the nose so this is the
very first step and once you condition
yourself to be breathing through your
nose
you're a lot of the way there because
that breath through the nose slows down
slows things down it's hard to
hyperventilate when you're breathing
through your nose right so that takes
care of a lot of those those rules and
regulations
i got to tell you this story man so i
had a guy called stephen mcginty on the
show he's just written a book about the
pisces three
submarine rescue which is the lo the
deepest ever submarine rescue i haven't
in about 1970. and these guys roger
malinson and roger chapman were stuck
15 000 feet down
in a submarine for 86
hours
on a bottle uh two bottles of oxygen
that were meant to last them sixty
so they were
talking through
the breath cycles that they needed to do
they were collecting the condensation
from their breath on the surface to
drink
they had oxygen tanks so what they were
doing and this was really really
interesting
they were purposefully alternating
between breathing through their nose
when they needed to make a decision
and breathing through their mouth when
they needed to conserve option oxygen
because the mouth breathing was
less
efficient but that's actually what they
wanted they didn't want to take as much
oxygen and they simply wanted to exist
so they tried to dial their breathing
down to about six breaths a minute and
breathe through their mouth
and then if they needed to do something
communicate with the surface run the
scrubber run the o2 tanks make a check
on some sort of uh measurements
then they'd breathe through their nose
for a little while beforehand
the headache
would abate a little bit
they would have a little bit more
cognitive function they'd do the thing
they go back to breathing through the
mouth quite slowly i thought that was
such an in-depth understanding of how
breath works and they stayed down there
on this bottle of oxygen for a day and a
half longer than they should have done
crazy
it's that that's a great story um and we
know that
nasal breathing uh affects how the brain
works so
there have been numerous studies there
was one a couple years ago out out of
northwestern university that was
fascinating looking at rhythmic slow
breathing through the nose and how
different areas of the brain will come
online and different congregations of
neurons will start lighting up in
different areas to allow communication
to work more fluidly between different
brain regions so the researchers said
that actually breathing through the nose
can help you make better decisions
because it's changing the neurochemistry
of your brain and the fact that these
guys knew about this in the 1970s is
really impressive because a lot of the
breathing research was coming out after
that time and you know you don't have to
tell them the importance of nasal
breathing or or how the body responds to
two different breaths i mean they
experienced it firsthand and what an
incredible story what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace